elle recherche aussi sociaux mitterrand
pourrait-il vous contraindre vous
convaincre et recueillir vos suffrages
en se contentant de vous assurer comme
il a tendance à le faire qu'il à
réconcilier les français avec la france
la france avec les français les français
avec les français et la france avec la
france il ya deux manières d'abuseurs un
peuple celle inondé de promesses
trompeuses
cela a été fait en 1981 ou bien c'est le
faire rêver mais pour le faire rêver il
faut là soupire c'est ce que l'on tente
aujourd'hui
bonne nuit les petits
comme lui et les petits faites de beaux
rêves tomber sur vous
deux autres
classique
je suis là
de tout